this week on world stories broiled US
Congress hit by allegations of sexual
misconduct smart trash digital disposal
in the Netherlands but we begin in
Nigeria and the story of a father
desperately looking for news of his
daughter she left Nigeria months ago in
an attempt to reach Europe via the
Mediterranean now John
omma kudou fears the worst a faded
pictures all that remains John O muku
whose daughter disappeared in February
she was 23 at the time a few weeks ago
John received a call she had been
abducted in Libya on her way to Europe
and he would have to pay a ransom the
farmer raised 600 euros but still has
yet to see any sign of life from his
daughter then last week John found out
about the deaths of 26 young Nigerian
women off the coast of Libya since then
I've not been myself not know half
address of mine I've been so worried
about it I don't know she's a monk or
she's not a mother cannot just tell
exactly
earlier this month a Spanish aid ship
rescued 400 Africans at sea but 26
Nigerian women were found dead at the
scene
their bodies floating in the water Italy
launched an investigation and arrested
two men on human trafficking charges
authorities also contacted the Nigerian
government but their response was muted
Austen arame and his team deals with
deaths like these on a daily basis the
activist is upset that the Nigerian
government his government is not doing
more pieces so no human being will be
satisfied with the level of response
that we are currently getting and that
is why I continue to see that
governments with all that the government
sees and claims that it is doing
government needs to do more arame says
it's a lack of opportunities at home
that's causing droves of young people to
flee
although Nigeria has one of the
strongest economies in Africa over 60
percent of its population live in
poverty
the government of course has a different
take on all this the mass exodus of
Nigerian youth has less to do with the
quality of life it says and more to do
with the lies being told by human
traffickers most of these people that
have crossed the Mediterranean Sea and
travel should you visit most of them
even graduates so if they are not
deceived to go and get and much more
greener pastures / dia do not embark on
such dangerous journeys so poverty
cannot really be the reason why we are
there embarking on such a journey
jonno Mikuru isn't really interested in
a political debate after his daughter
disappeared he started working evenings
as a taxi driver to make some extra
money he may need it if he has to he
will travel to Libya himself to look for
his daughter
to the u.s. now and the allegations of
sexual misconduct sweeping through the
corridors of power the system therefore
registering a complaint is at its best
opaque and Capitol Hill says one
congresswoman a hostile environment
everything is about sex except for sex
sex is about power and it's always been
about power on Capitol Hill says Reid's
Everson here former congressional
employees are now saying me too exposing
the inconvenient truth that the law
makers of the world's most powerful
country also have a sexual harassment
problem he said are you going to be good
and I said yeah he said well if you're
gonna be good what's the point of you
coming and I said huh
he said will you flirt with me that was
me not understanding that I was being
groomed or being invited to a sexual
relationship Everson used to be a fellow
at the Congressional Black Caucus when
she was approached by a Congress member
she does not want to name and her case
is by no means unique Rebecca ware was
just 22 years old when she says
congressman Gary Miller harassed her he
just said my god Rebecca he looked just
amazing really stunning today
would you mind twirling for me and at
the time I was young I really didn't
know what to do in that moment except to
comply and I was just trying to kind of
shake it off and regroup when I got a
phone call from our Washington office
saying congratulations Rebecca we don't
know what you did but Gary just called
and said that you should have a bonus of
$1,250 immediately
wait didn't find a complaint but the
women who do try face challenges unique
to Congress says sexual harassment
attorney Deborah cuts the law was
designed in a way that is very skewed
and protects the members to the
disadvantage of complainants so it's a
very stacked system the unique system on
Capitol Hill creates an environment in
which congressmen can easily get away
with sex
harassment I didn't have the tools or
the capacity to complain I would have
been fired it was just as simple as that
and congressional interns of fellows
like Everson do not even have the right
to go through an already convoluted
process of complaining Congress is
slowly grappling with sexual harassment
within its own ranks it has agreed that
mandatory training is now necessary but
changing its culture if abused power and
sexual misconduct will take far longer
as it likely will nationwide too
in recent years Turkey has opened its
borders to nearly 3 million Syrian and
Iraqi refugees many of whom have been
able to set up small businesses but in
some Istanbul neighborhoods tensions
have been boiling over
the Nassim barbershop is popular among
Syrians nearly everyone who works here
is from Syria this is the owner 24 year
old Mahmoud al-ayam
Istanbul has been good to him although
he left Syria only five years ago with
his brothers help he now has a
barbershop a restaurant and a clothing
company of course Syrians can do
business here Syrians are not generally
unsuccessful Syrians are ambitious sure
a few cause trouble but they don't
represent the majority there are too
many rumors about what Syrians might
have done and how the Turks have
responded but they're just bad-mouthing
Syrians casting them in a bad light
anyone who has dreams and goals can come
and make them happen here marmots
restaurant like all of his businesses is
in the a thin layer district it's one of
his damn balls poorest and most densely
populated areas out of the half million
inhabitants their local officials say as
many as 1/5 of Syrians like Marmot many
Syrians have opened up businesses in
essen lap the government made it easier
for Syrians to set up shop by waiving
the restrictions non-citizens normally
face but that success is starting to
cause unease among some local Turks
after a while they got used to being
here and started opening more and more
shops they've slowly started to
establish their own sectors and now they
only go to Syrian shops they have a
jeweler store up there you'll see they
don't pay their taxes they're given all
the breaks but when we want to open a
shop the state is harder than us we're
not given any of the benefits they get
but not everyone sees the Syrians as a
threat those Syrians are all working
they have families they are Muslims
living among us we don't look at the
situation as Syrians and Turks but as
one Muslim community
so in the spirit of the district's motto
a city of peace and hope the people of
Essen lair are still striving to resolve
their differences amicably with their
Syrian neighbors rubbish collection an
expensive business for cities and often
inefficient but what if there was a way
for the trash container itself to signal
whether it was full or not this report
from The Hague
man rears Aroo doesn't know where his
job will take him today for years he and
his colleagues had set routes now they
change every day he sees on his tablet
which containers to empty the
information comes from sensors installed
inside around 1,400 underground garbage
containers in the hague around 500 tons
of household waste are thrown away in
the city every day but only some
containers get so full that they need to
be emptied it took him some getting used
to but he understands the advantages
it's better because you only empty the
bins that are actually full so it saves
a lot of time you can do more and only
do what's necessary two years ago the
waste disposal service hague mil your
services introduced the sensor system
made by the finnish start-up nfo they
won't say how much it cost
the sensors transmit data four times a
day which the staff can use to predict
when the containers will be full for the
company it's about saving money
long-term and being able to make more
accurate assessments but there are other
reasons
if the bins are not full 10 20 30 % it
doesn't require emptying it so it would
be better for the environment for the
traffic jams for the blocking of the
streets for the safety of the people on
the street to empty at once in two weeks
for instance instead of two times a week
so it's all quality and environment
those were the main goals why we
introduced here Knafo sensors an EVO
system is met with skepticism in a lot
of countries but they're convinced that
automation and online networking will
also spread to waste management the
hague wants to permanently install
sensors in all seven thousand plus
containers in the city despite the
increased productivity there are no
plans to cut jobs
Saru and his colleagues aren't worried
they still have plenty to do and there's
no slacking off now
wait yeah yeah uh yeah my system sees
where you are in every location they can
see on the screen straight away what
you've collected and what you haven't
that means less wasted time and effort
and less likelihood the city is throwing
away its money
you